nous avons le plaisir de vous accueillir
à cette conférence de presse qui a pour
objet de vous présenter les résultats de
la consultation et du sondage réalisé
par le sénat à l'écouté des élus locaux
et notamment par sa délégation aux
collectivités territoriales dont je
saigne la présidente françoise gatel qui
est à mes côtés
ces consultations ont été réalisés dans
la perspective de l'examen prochain du
projet de loi cadre des la commission
des lois
son président françois noël buffet ou à
nous rejoindre a désigné pour ce qui la
concerne ses deux co rapporteurs mathieu
darnaud et françoise gatel et ils vous
présenteront après la restitution de nos
consultations
la méthode que le sénat entend mettre en
oeuvre pour amender et enrichir le
projet de loi dans le prolongement de
ses travaux en matière de
décentralisation faudrait rappeler le
travail réalisé autour de engagement et
proximité c'est une illustration de
cette méthode me semble-t-il
les apports du sénat sur les questions
de sécurité s'étant nouri d'une
consultation des directs des mères via
la plateforme internet et à sondages le
sénat a rendu public vous en souvenez
c'était en juillet 2020 50 propositions
pour le plein exercice des libertés
locales au nom d'un groupe de travail
rassemblant l'ensemble de ses
sensibilités
autour d'une conviction la nécessité de
renforcer l'efficacité de l'action
publique
et souvenez vous c'était une des deux
contributions du sénat au plan de
relance
demandé par le président de la
république emmanuel macron ces
propositions appelé et appelle un
nouveau souffle de décentralisation
elles sont aussi notre contribution il
s'agit de faire le pari des territoires
en s'appuyant sur leur force
d'innovation et les dynamiques qui sont
à l'oeuvre
c'est aussi le pari de la confiance
envers des élus locaux
ce que je qualifie mois de désir de
décentralisation quarante ans après les
lois defferre à chacun de mes échanges
avec les maires et présidents d'interco
c'est les présidents de départements et
de régions je constate qu'il existe dans
notre pays une vraie vraie envie de
décentralisation c'est ce que confirme
notre consultation auprès des maires de
france et le sondage auprès des français
sur leur vision des collectivités
territoriales françoise gatel va vous le
présenter dans un instant le message est
clair les français réclament moins
discours moins de bureaucratie plus de
proximité en fait plus de résultats au
fond nos concitoyens dresse ce constat
d'une urgence à décentraliser l'exercice
de nouvelles politiques publiques et à
simplifier les règles d'organisation des
collectivités au fort parce qu'ils
attendent une meilleure prise en compte
de leurs besoins et ils attendent des
résultats le président de la république
avait posé ses tailleurs ce diagnostic
à l'issue du grand débat après la crise
des gilets jaunes ils avaient ressentir
le roger d'un pouvoir trop vertical qui
appelait à plus de proximité dans la
décision
depuis la crise sanitaire me semble
avoir parachevé la démonstration d'un
état fragilisé par ses rigidités et il a
confirmé l a confirmé cette crise
l'agilité et la réactivité des
collectivités territoriales demain le
gouvernement va présenter en conseil des
ministres sa loi cadre des
différenciations décentralisation
déconcentration des complexification ce
projet de loire létard ne répond pas
tout à fait aux attentes
j'ai vu dans un excellent journal
paraissant en fin de matinée que pour 47
présidente département il en était de
même
ce matin donc au fond quand nous disons
que les associations de lui il retrouve
pas l'essentiel des propositions qu'ils
ont formulées j'allais dire non plus les
sénateurs qui ont fait ces fameux 50
propositions mais le mérite et qu'il y à
un texte demain sur la table et que nous
n'allons pas bouder ce texte mais au
contraire lui donner de la force lui
donner un certain nombre d'éléments à
partir de propositions concrètes
le projet doit cadets et pourrait devra
donc être déposée demain devant le
bureau du sénat examinait en première
instance par nous conformément à la
constitution
il a le mérite je le disais il ya un
instant d'aborder concrètement un
certain nombre de sujets qui sont autant
de compétences clés pour les
collectivités territoriales
je crois mais je laisserai nos deux
futurs rapporteur puisqu'il reste une
journée de l'allaitement
en attendant que texte soit soient
déposées je crois que le sénat
s'attachera à l'enrichir tant sur les
questions de décentralisation que sur
les questions de déconcentration fort
des apports des associations d'élus fort
de l'expertisé de la commission des lois
fort du travail aussi de son président
françois noël buffet notre assemblée va
s'appuyer sur ces trois propositions de
loi pour le renforcement des libertés
locales qui traitait déjà de
différenciation décentralisation et de
déconcentration
concernant la différenciation c'est pour
ma part un regret puisque lé sénat avait
proposé d'aller plus loin que ne le fait
le texte 4d en complétant la loi
organique du 19 avril 19 avril 2021 sur
l'expérimentation notamment les
dispositions destinées à favoriser
l'expérimentation des collectivités
resteront exercer un droit
constitutionnel constant sur le
fondement de l'article 72 3 donc
composer avec une capacité expérimentés
qui sera plus souple sur la forme
certes mais
qui demeurera sur le fond
concernant la décentralisation et sur
les sujets des compétences que vous
l'aurez pragmatique je pense aux
communes
or à donner plus de souplesse
d'organisation au sein des
intercommunalités moins de contraintes
également puisque le projet de loi
abordera la prolongation du dispositif
sru c'est un point sur lequel nous
veillerons pour les départements se fera
l'affirmation de leurs compétences en
matière médico social mais aussi une
capacité en faveur de l'économie de
proximité et concernant les régions nous
avons exprimé notre volonté de renforcer
leurs compétences en matière de santé en
matière d'emploi et d'économie
mais j'insiste aussi sur le bloc
communal qui est un élément important et
notamment la commune enfin nous
entendrons traiter le volet de la
déconcentration avec une ambition
véritable supérieure à celle du projet
de loi car en force et l'état au plan
local c'est répondre à une demande des
élus mais aussi je le pensais une
attente de nos concitoyens
le sénat propose de restaurer l'autorité
du préfet du département
c'est un choix fort à un moment
paradoxale où le gouvernement nous
annonce qu'il veut mettre fin au corps
préfectoral
je n'évoquerai pas le bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon mais je souhaite
rappeler combien dans la crise
le pays tout entier a pu s'appuyer sur
le corps préfectoral à travers notamment
ses relations avec les élus locaux et le
couple maire préfet tant chanté dans les
psaumes actuelle et bien c'est
aujourd'hui une réalité
pourquoi casser cette réalité c'est pour
cela que l'examen de ce projet doit
quête d devrait être abordé avec
l'ambition d'en faire un texte fort
le projet de loi doit remettre permet de
construire un nouvel équilibre des
pouvoirs entre état et collectivités
territoriales de nature à restaurer la
confiance c'est le contraire un instant
le sens de la tribune de ce jour publié
dans lequel je note que il y a les
présidents des deux groupes ii le groupe
de gauche comme du groupe de droite et
du centre et des indépendants de l'adf
qui est le groupe majoritaire qui ont
signé
ensemble cette tribune au fond il faut
plus de liberté pour les collectivités
territoriales
voilà on a même la présidente quelques
mots pour dire l'importance que nous
attachons au sénat et que le président
du sénat attache aux travaux que vous
conduisez vous cède immédiatement la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président pour cette introduction et
merci à tous
donc le projet de loi 4d le sénat
propose de le pousser un pont plus loin
ou une lettre plus loin pour atteindre
le d'efficacité le président du sénat
l'a indiqué l'objectif ou l'obsession
c'est l'efficacité de l'action publique
deux crises successives ont prouvé
l'exigence d'efficacité la crise des
gilet jaune mais aussi la crise la crise
sanitaire et c'est l'efficacité de
l'action publique jusqu'au dernier
kilomètre et le président marché l'a
rappelé dans cet objectif le sénat sous
la conduite du président a formulé 50
propositions avec cet objectif bien
précis de l'efficacité et donc il
s'agissait au travers de la consultation
que nous avons lancé à la fois par le
biais d'une enquête csa mais aussi une
consultation internet de tous les élus
locaux dans leur diversité de tester
l'adhésion et la pertinence de nos
propositions
cette consultation réalisée par la
délégation collectivité a réuni 3000 300
répondants ce qui est fort significative
qu'en résultat je crois que c'est la
troisième consultation la plus
fructueuse de l'histoire du sénat et le
sénat le csa pardon lui a basé son
sondage sur un échantillon représentatif
des trois niveaux de collectivités
communes départements et régions cette
consultation comme ce sondage convergent
autour de six grandes attentes que nous
allons développer
je vais les cités rapidement la première
c'est aller plus loin dans la
décentralisation mais sans big bang
territorial c'est il faut laisser
derrière
nous les grands chamboulements des lois
nos pour éviter de refaire un big bang
territorial qui serait aussi au hasard
de la deuxième à temps c'est
l'adaptation des politiques publiques
aux réalités territoriales avec la
différenciation territoriales ce qui est
déjà inscrit e dans la loi je prends
l'exemple de la différenciation entre
des dispositions qui concernent des
communes du littoral ou des communes de
montagne
le troisième point qui est extrêmement
important c'est celui de l'efficacité
dans la proximité exercer les
compétences au plus près du terrain par
ce principe qui est la subsidiarité et
qui doit être celui qui guide
l'élaboration d'une architecture
d'organisation pour atteindre
l'efficacité et encore une fois la crise
sanitaire n'a cessé de montrer la vérité
de ce principe de subsidiarité
le quatrième point c'est la
simplification des normes applicables
aux collectivités territoriales je
rappelle qu'à mer est confronté à 400000
norme dans la gestion de son quotidien
il ya une exigence d'une homme qui soit
intelligente qui ne contreviennent pas à
l'action publique
cinquième point c'est donner plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités territoriales
nous l'avons vu pendant la crise
sanitaire avec la relation difficile
entre les ars et les acteurs de terrain
qui pouvaient répondre à la mise en
oeuvre des de l'organisation qui
convenait et enfin le président a
rappelé son importance
et ça c'est une attente très forte qui
est exprimée s'est renforcé l'état
territorial autour du préfet dans un
échelon départemental qui a montré sa
pertinence encore une fois pendant
pendant cette crise donc nous allons
prendre ses attentes une par une
donc je le disais une attente de
décentralisation il ne s'agit pas là
encore de contester les compétences
régaliennes de l'état
mais je crois qu'il y à une naissance
cité d'une alliance très positive entre
l'état et les collectivités et que
l'état ne saurait faire sans les
collectivités qu'il faut savoir faire
confiance je donnerai un exemple assez
frappant qui est celui d'un dimanche de
juin de 2020 ou le président de la
république à 18 heures annonce était une
excellente chose que tous les élèves de
france doivent retourner dans leurs
établissements scolaires le lundi qui
suivait le président de la république
est rentré à l'elysée alors sans doute
yat-il son lot de soucis mais je sais
que tous les maires de france qui ont
des établissements scolaires se sont
spontanément mise au travail pour voir
comment ils allaient pouvoir eux
organiser ce qui leur incombait
stellaire l'ouverture des écoles
l'ouverture des services périscolaires
et des cantines donc l'état doit être
centré sur ses compétences régaliennes
et décentraliser ce qui doit l'être pour
avoir plus d'efficacité nous en
reparlerons sans doute au niveau des ars
la deuxième attente c'est celle d'une
adaptation des politiques publiques aux
réalités territoriales alors très
souvent ce mode on va dire parfois de
différenciation ou de différence tu
coures fait un peu peur parce que cela
consisterait à rompre avec le principe
d'égalité mais rompre va dire qu'en
faisant cela on rompt avec l'égalité
c'est qu'au fond égalité uniformité et
que le conseil constitutionnel lui-même
a dit combien dès lors qu'il y avait des
solutions différentes dans un respect
des principes d'égalité n'était pas une
infraction constitutionnel si je puis
dire
donc nous l'avons vu avec mathieu
dandenault d'engagement et proximité
combien nous avons défendu cette idée
qu'au sein des intercommunalités il
pouvait y avoir des répartitions de
compétences entre les communes et les
intercommunalités je pourrais parler de
l'eau et l'assainissement mais de bien
d'autres sujets et comment on peut avoir
au sein de ma vie collective
d ou de collectivités de même catégorie
des compétences différentes on le voit
aujourd'hui avec la compétence
européenne d'alsace et surtout les élus
sont très attachés à ce principe de
volontariat que l'on retrouve dans le
texte sur l'expérimentation
je crois qu'il s'agit le président l'a
rappelé de faire appel au sens de la
responsabilité des élus locaux et
d'avoir confiance dans leur capacité à
fabriquer des solutions qui soient les
plus adaptées à leur territoire
la table numéro 3 portes sur l'exercice
des compétences au plus près des
réalités du terrain je crois qu'il ya un
objectif qui doit réunir l'état les
collectivités qui est le nôtre qui est
celui de l'efficacité de l'action
publique jusqu'au dernier kilomètre et
cet objectif d'efficacité ne peut être
atteint que par un principe qui est un
principe de subsidiarité qui peut le
mieux exercer telle ou telle compétence
pour servir nos concitoyens parce que
nous avons aussi une exigence de
proximité nous l'avons vu dans la crise
sanitaire il président larcher a
l'habitude de dire que les élus locaux
sont dans une proximité d'efficacité
parce qu'ils sont apportés d'engueulades
ils doivent pour leur champ de
compétence fabriquer les solutions les
plus les plus adaptées donc ce principe
de subsidiarité c'est vraiment le
principe qui doit nous guider dans une
construction d' architecture basée sur
la confiance dans les élus et leurs
libertés a inventé des solutions
l'attendent numéro 4 est une alors cela
relève de l'exigence et de l'obsession
et l'obsession pardon des normes est une
obsession que nous partageons avec le
président lambert du conseil national
d'évaluation des normes dont nous avons
fait pas à la ministre madame de
moche à la parce que aujourd'hui la
norme elle a tendance à contrevenir à
l'efficacité de l'action publique alors
que la norme
elle doit servir l'action publique pour
sécuriser et protéger et vous voyez sur
cette diapos deux couleurs la couleur
bleue la plus adroite et le nombre de
fois où cet item est revenu en priorité
donc vous voyez que 78 % des élus qui
ont répondu à ceux à notre consultation
érige la simplification de la norme en
exigence absolue parce que les élus sont
confrontés non seulement à une
on va dire une inflation normative
récurrente à une contradiction de
certaines de ces normes
ce qui fait que parfois une norme qui
peut être à caractère environnemental
bien content revue vient contrarier une
norme qui est une norme en matière de
sécurité
la tante numéro 4 s'est donc simplifier
ces normes je les dis vous voyez que il
y à plus de 90% des nuls qui sont
favorables à la création d'une instance
de concertation auprès du préfet
c'est un sujet extrêmement important que
le sénat a apporté
il n'y a pas un élu local qui n'a pas
été un jour confrontés parce qu'il
pouvait avoir un projet d'urbanisme ou
un autre projet à une succession de
rencontres avec des services de l'état
qui chacun et mettez un avis dans son
sujet dans son expertise sur le projet
de la commune ce qui faisait que c'est à
vite et parfois contradictoires ou en
tout cas il était inconciliables et que
donc nous avons proposé ce qui a été
fait notamment dans un rapport rémy
pointereau avait fait qu'il premier
vice-président à la délégation en charge
de la simplification c'est la création
d'une instance de concertation auprès du
préfet quand il y a 6 à vis de l'état
sur un sujet il faut qu'il y ait un chef
d'orchestre si vous êtes il faut qu'il y
ait un préfet qui harmonie
et qui décide pour que les élus puissent
agir l'attendent numéro 5 concerne les
pouvoirs qui doivent être données aux
collectivités encore une fois dans ce
souci d'efficacité en matière de santé
il faut distinguer ce qui relève de la
compétence régalienne de l'état et ce
qui relève de l'organisation et de
l'accès aux soins pour tous et nous
l'avons vu au niveau des agences
régionales de santé ou les élus locaux
qui ont un certain nombre de
responsabilités quand ils doivent
proposer des aménagements du territoire
garantir l'accessibilité par des
solutions de transport à l'hôpital
il faut que les élus locaux choix
beaucoup plus impliqué dans le conseil
de surveillance drs le sénat avait
proposé que la présidence du conseil de
surveillance soit confié un élu local et
qu'il y ait un rééquilibrage de la
composition en faveur des représentants
des territoires et proposer cela ça
n'est en aucun cas renier la compétence
régalienne de l'état
mais la mise en oeuvre doit être fait
dans un dialogue entre état et
collectivités et nous avons aussi un
vrai sujet concernant le département qui
est le chant d'excellence de la
compétence sociale
nous avons vu pendant la crise sanitaire
que les ehpad ont deux tutelles l'état
par la rs et les collectivités locales
et j'ai entendu des présidentes
département parmi les plus éminents dire
que au moment le plus fort de la crise
où il y avait dans beaucoup des pâtes
des clusters le directeur de la rs
n'avait jamais pris contact avec le
président du département qui lui a une
responsabilité aussi dans ce chantre
donc il nous semble important qu'il y
ait une seule tutelle est un autre point
très important c'est celui de la
médecine scolaire
alors pourquoi confier la médecine
scolaire rhône au département parce que
je crois aujourd'hui ça ne remet pas en
cause les personnels
de médecine scolaire de l'éducation
nationale mais il ya une grande
indigence une grande insuffisance en
médecine scolaire et que les
départements ont la compétence sociale
de prévention et de la petite enfance et
il nous semble judicieux
parce que plus efficace que les
départements puissent contenu de cette
compétence être aussi dans les lieux où
ils vont détecter des difficultés de
santé des difficultés sociales d'enfants
qui ne vont pas consultée chez un
médecin mais ces enfants sont à l'école
et donc ses enfants seront vus il s'agit
d'aller vers de façon à prévenir et
prendre en charge très tôt des enfants
ou des familles l'attendent numéro 6 le
président l'a rappelé elle est
particulièrement d'actualité stelian
d'un point de vue totalement différent
de la part des élus locaux sur l'état
territorial les élus locaux sont en
attente très forte d'un état territorial
plutôt à l'échelle d'un département
parce que c'est l'échelle de la
proximité parce qu' il ne peut pas y
avoir d'action publique sans une
concertation étroite entre l'état et les
collectivités ce sont des partenaires
qui sont absolument indissociables et
pendant la crise sanitaire
on a vu combien dans les préfectures ou
s'organiser en mode 2 on va dire
commando en période de crise où le
préfère réunissait autour de lui des
élus mais l'ensemble des agences de
l'état et des services déconcentrés
permettait d'être réactive et permettait
d'avoir une action coordonnée et donc le
sénat et les élus locaux confirment ce
que nous avions préconisé au pressenti à
temps de manière extrêmement fort parce
que aujourd'hui on est en état on va
dire d'insuffisance d'efficacité que
autour du préfet soient réunies ou en
tout cas que le préfet puisse coordonner
des agences qui sont des agences
autonomes comme les agences régionales
de santé qui ne rendent des comptes
alors ministre mais aussi la direction
régionale des finances c'est aussi vrai
pour la direction de l'éducation
nationale où il nous faut un état
territorial fort qu'ils soient
concentrés pour avoir plus d'efficacité
éviter de s'éparpiller comme indiqué le
gain de célèbres façon puzzle qui en
période de crise est assez antinomique
avec l'efficacité
pour terminer je crois que nous pouvons
être heureux si je puis dire de des
propositions que le sénat a fait parce
que elles sont dans conforme aux
attentes des élus et quand on dit que le
sénat et la chambre des territoires on
le vérifie et je crois que les attentes
sont d'autant plus fortes qu'aujourd'hui
elle relève d'un comment dire elle
relève de fait elles relèvent de deux
situations qu'elles nous avons été
confrontés pendant ces deux crises ldj
les jaunes et celle le de la crise
sanitaire et que je crois que les crises
révèle à la fois les failles et les
faiblesses mais elle nous oblige en ce
sens que nous devons guérir de nos maux
m11x pour envisager une organisation
différente c'est ci devant être complété
par une évaluation plus rigoureuse des
lois qui sont faites mais aussi pas un
champ d'expérimentation qui permet
d'avoir une approche plus scientifique
qui sans doute parfois plus efficaces
je vous remercie les questions voilà
très très brièvement merci monsieur
président celui d'un collègue
co-rapporteur françoise gatel peut être
un mot sur la méthode 1 que nous
souhaitons voir prévaloir pour
appréhender au mieux ce texte je
voudrais simplement rappeler qu'il y à
un peu moins de 4 ans ici même dans
cette salle le président de la
république lancé la conférence nationale
des territoires et venait
finalement exposé ce qui devait être la
politique territoriale de la majorité
actuelle et la volonté du président de
la république notamment lors de cette
conférence de presse à l'époque de
mettre en place ce qu'il a appelé les
préfets simplificateur or les préfet
simplificateur finalement ont été
réduits à leur plus simple expression et
on en arrive aujourd'hui comme le disait
un instant président du sénat a envisagé
la suppression du corps électoral tout
ça pour dire que a du corps corps
préfectoral pardon tout ça tout ça tout
ça pour dire que finalement assez à ses
errements et à cette méthode qui n'est
fait que d'hésitations et de petits pas
nous avons souhaité proposer ici même au
sénat une constance notamment pour
essayer de construire et d'élaborer des
textes qui comme vient de le dire
françoise comme l'a dit le président
larcher sont avant tout l'émanation des
inspirations et des aspirations pardon
de l'ensemble des élus territoriaux
je rappelle ici même que ce que nous
défendons aujourd'hui nous ne défendions
déjà lors de l'examen de la loi note
c'est à dire une décentralisation qui
soit plus aboutie qu il y ait des pans
de compétences qu'ils soient déléguées
transférés dans leur ensemble aux
collectivités territoriales qu'il
s'agisse de la région qu'il s'agisse des
départements je pense notamment à la
compétence économique
autant dire que nous n'avons pas varié
sur sur ses positions et que nous
entendons bien faire de même aujourd'hui
que ce soit au travers de la
consultation que viens d'évoquer
françoise gatel au travers aussi des
différents textes que nous avons voté
ici même des travaux que nous avons
menées il y à un peu plus d'un an et qui
ont donné lieu à assez 50 propositions
qui sont autant de constats faits
établis comme des conclusions partielles
de la crise sanitaire que nous venons de
traverser que
finalement des constats que nous avons
élaborée dans le temps et puis dernières
consultations et concertations
importante bien sûr celle qui passe par
les associations d'élus et notamment
territoire unis avec lesquels nous avons
souhaité travailler depuis maintenant un
certain nombre de mois et d'années pour
essayer de faire en sorte que soit
entendu tout les niveaux toutes les
strates de collectivité parce que pour
nous c'est important que chacun trouve
sa place avec la volonté justement de
donner aussi un peu plus d'agilité
notamment réaffirmant la liberté
conventionnels parce qu'on sait que
lorsqu'on parle de différenciation
territoriales c'est aussi pour nous la
volonté de prendre en considération les
différentes problématiques et les
différentes réalités territoriales et
cette agilité que nous appelons de nos
voeux cette subsidiarité auquel
françoise gatel faisait référence c'est
aussi la marque qui est celle du du
sénat pour trouver des solutions qui
conviennent aux territoires de montagne
au territoire de plaine au territoire du
littoral parce que chacun à la nécessité
de faire entendre sa voix et sa
spécificité c'est bien à partir de
l'ensemble de ces éléments que nous
allons travailler appréhender cette loi
cadre des en essayant tant que faire se
peut de lui redonner un souffle qui de
notre avis commun et partagé n'est pas
suffisamment présents dans ce texte il y
a des choses parfois même des choses
intéressantes mais il ya aussi beaucoup
de manques notamment eu égard à skis
évoqué le président larcher à l'instant
et qui s'est traduit par cette tribune
des 47 présidente département parce que
on peut parler autant que l'on veut de
transfert de compétences d'exercice de
compétences mais tout cela ne saurait
fonctionner si on n'a pas aussi les
ressources et des moyens qui vont avec
et c'est je crois un des sujets sur
lequel le bât blesse est que nous allons
nous efforcer de corriger au travers de
l'examen de la préparation de ce texte
je vous remercie et puis je crois qu'on
peut peut-être maintenant vous passez la
parole en vous demandant d' activer
votre micro et votre caméra pour celles
et ceux qui souhaitent s'exprimer
c'est parfait
[Musique]
ah bon
ou pas
oui je vous en prie vous avez vous avez
là la parole sur le mode opératoire que
mon collègue mathieu darnaud à préciser
tout à l'heure donc vous pouvez indiquer
votre soin de poser une question via
l'outil de chat tout va bien bonjour
noël gaultier du média social concernant
les ehpad dont vous préconisez à une
reprise en main par le département des
ehpad
comment les départements pourraient
gérer la partie médicale des ehpad qui
est actuellement du ressort des ars et
at il une autre question je prend
directement celle là
mais un meurtre outils pour le moniteur
j'aurais aimé que pour revenu sur la
question de la loi sru a été évoqué en
introduction par le président très bien
je peux proposer une première réponse
une première réflexion sur les sur les
ehpad
vous avez évoqué monsieur la
particularité la complexité du
financement des ehpad ce qui est une
partie médicale et donc que de soins il
y à une partie qui relève de la
solidarité des départements je pense que
la réflexion que nous devons aux
conduits on doit prendre en compte cette
complexité de fonctionnement à partir
d'un objectif qui est celui de
l'efficacité de la gestion des pâtes
je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire
l'économie de réfléchir aux conséquences
de cette double tutelle en période de
crise où certains présidents de
départements nous l'ont dit ce qui se
passait dans les ehpad relevait du champ
de l'invisible parce que les
départements
considérant qu'il s'agissait là d'une
situation sanitaire et de santé
confiait la gestion assez naturellement
de la crise au à la rs et la rs était
dans une gestion du cluster qui ne
prenait pas en compte le personnel des
ehpad ni les résidentes dans les ehpad
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on sache un
peu gérer la complexité mais que ce
champ là doit être absolument couvert et
que la double tutelle mais on retrouve
aussi ça dans la gestion des personnels
des lycées ou des départements où on a
eu une attribution de champ de
compétence qui n'est pas entière et on
doit en tout cas s'assurer évalué
l'opérationnalité et l'efficacité de
cantine présidentes de département qui
aujourd'hui ministre et qui était
président
deux départements dans une région où il
y avait 1 kloster quand elle dit
lorsqu'on a évalué l'impact de la crise
sanitaire pour les collectivités au
printemps dernier quand elle dit que le
directeur de l'est n'a jamais contacté
un directeur d'ehpad parce qu'il pensait
que c'était le département qu'il faisait
vous voyez bien que l'on à des
défaillances parce que l'organisation
n'ait pas pensé
donc là encore je pense qu'on a une
exigence de tirer les leçons de la crise
et qu'on ne peut pas avoir deux tutelles
qui qui s'ignorent absolument sur la
seconde question sur la loi sru
je laisserai si mon collègue mathieu
darnaud complété en a dans cette loi
cadets tout un volet de logements qui en
choix au départ peut paraître un peu
incongru parce que la loi 4 dès que nous
nous appelons plutôt de nos voeux à être
une oie eux c'est à dire la loi de
l'efficacité proposait de revenir sur
l'organisation territoriale pour plus
d'efficacité et on était plutôt sur les
répartitions de compétences des uns et
des autres et on a glissé dans ce texte
un volet logement important parce que je
crois que le gouvernement souhaitait
pourra faire une loi sur le logement et
que dans le calendrier législatif qui
court jusqu'à la présidentielle le temps
ne permettait pas sans doute d'avoir
plusieurs textes c'est donc on est venu
faire une sorte de grève sur cadets avec
la loi sru qui je pense est comme un
feuilleton
c'est à dire ces deux lois ne cesse
d'être d'être retravaillées d'être
abondée d'être retravaillées en tout cas
parce qu'on voit bien que encore une
fois cette loi sru elle est l'exemple
même de ce que nous contestons en ce
sens que c'est une norme qui a été
définie notamment l'article 55
en termes de logements sociaux par
catégories de communes et l'on voit bien
aujourd'hui que cette norme extrêmement
rigide et extrêmement simpliste et
justine appliqua et n'atteint pas son
résultat en matière de mixité de
logements et qu'il faut s'en vont
retravailler ce sujet de l' équilibre en
matière de logement dans un champ qui
peut être celui de l'intercommunalité
oui justin un mot en complément parce
que je fais bien les propos de françoise
gatel finalement ces deux sujets ils ont
un point commun c'est qu'on souhaite
aussi redonné de l'agilité de la et de
la souplesse sur la loi sru
l'idée n'est pas temps de revenir sur
l'article 55 de laisser une marge
d'adaptation aux collectivités qui sont
soumises à des contraintes très fortes
que ce soit quelle contrainte de
pression foncière que ce soit des
contraintes liées tout simplement aux
capacités en matière de construction de
nouveaux logements de gestion des parcs
existants
peut-être réfléchir aussi à la question
de ddr intercommunale donc autant de
sujets qui vont nous amener à réfléchir
mais on est partis du même constat c'est
à dire qu'il fallait concerter les élus
une concertation a été menée notamment
par la commission des affaires
économiques qui permettra de faire
remonter des problèmes très concrets
parce qu'avant tout il faut revenir à
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire aux
problématiques concrètes auxquelles sont
confrontés les élus on est souvent dans
des grands discours dans des intentions
des incantations mais nous au sénat on
souhaite avant tout se mettre dans la
réalité des choses que la réalité vécue
par par nos élus et il en va de même sur
la question de la gestion des ehpad
là aussi m de l'agilité vous allez avoir
certains départements qui ont les moyens
financiers de gérer l'ensemble des ehpad
et qui pourront justement par rapport à
ce que vous évoquez à la question des
ars prendre la compétence dans son
ensemble sans que ça ne pose problème et
puis vous aurez des départements moi je
viens départements l'ardèche où on sait
que c'est quelque chose de très
compliqué parce qu'on a une pyramide des
âges parce qu'on a une sociologie en
matière de population qui fait que c'est
un poids
en matière de solidarité qui pèsent
considérablement et où il faudra trouver
une forme d' agiter qui permettra
d'associer l'ensemble des acteurs donc
notre volonté c'est aussi celle ci s'est
pas d'aborder les sujets de façon
dogmatique et rigide c'est voir comment
on peut apporter des solutions aux élus
dans les territoires en donnant
justement plus de liberté plus d'agilité
c'est en ce sens que nous formulerons
des propositions sur ce sur ce texte
cadet il y à trois questions à venir
césar arman de la tribune patrick roger
du monde et arnaud payet de la flore
césar arman si vous voulez bien poser la
première question de cette série vous
ans et ont perdu
bon bah écoute et patrick roger vous
passer de la deuxième à la première
classe jeu
merci à vous que cécile puis me
permettre
les j'ai l'impression que autour de ce
projet de loi trois quatre départs dont
il y a énormément de postures ce qui
n'est pas étonnant
à un an de l'élection présidentielle
si bon si
reprend les propositions de loi du sénat
est le projet de loi tel qu'il va être
présenté demain en conseil des ministres
beaucoup de propositions sont
convergentes
je dirai au moins la moitié
peut-être même plus dans ces conditions
quelle va être la la manière dont le
sénat va aborder cette ce projet de loi
est ce qu'il s'agit de faire de
l'obstruction ou est ce que en
définitive vous vous dites ce congé de
moi
nous l'avons souhaité nous l'avons voulu
nous y avons contribué et l'important
c'est que pour nous et la beauty ce je
me permets de répondre sur le principe
puisque j'ai vu la ministre il ya peu de
temps et on peut rendre hommage à la
ténacité de la ministre et au soutien
d'ailleurs du premier ministre pour que
le texte dont le destin n'était pas
assuré et dont le risque était de
s'appeler 5d le d de disparition et donc
je pense que ça c'est un premier point
et reprenant le principe de la
rochefoucauld que j'aime tant il est nul
difficultés qu'un homme ou une femme
d'esprit ne puisse transformer en succès
en l'état actuel et je le tiens de l'
échange que j'ai eu avec la ministre
dans l'état actuel les propositions du
texte monsieur roger je souhaite que vos
chiffres soit exact à l'arrivée du texte
nous partîmes avec 20 convergence nous
pouvons en avoir 30 et notre rêve serait
d' approcher les 50
c'est exactement les chances que nous
avons eues avec la ministre après
l'homme et la femme d'esprit sont de
part et d'autre de moi même
ils vont pouvoir vous répondre mais
personnellement comme président du sénat
je pense que nous n'avons pas le droit
pour les collectivités territoriales de
faire parce que ça n'a pas commencé
monsieur roger dans une poche
sur un an d'élections présidentielles
dois je vous rappeler le congrès de
septembre 2018 à marseille est en fait
l'échec de la conférence nationale des
territoires au point que conférence
nationale des territoires nous y croyons
tellement que moi même avec françoise
gatel et mathieu darnaud nous étions
membres de cette conférence nationale
des territoires et donc territoire unis
c'est le constat qu'elle n'arrivait pas
à se mettre en place dans l'esprit du
discours du président de la république
que mathieu darnaud à rappeler ici le 17
juillet 2017
et donc c'est pas une posture
c'est toujours lui la nécessité de ce
besoin face à la recentralisation qui
n'a pas commencé
je le dis clairement en mai 2010 est
d'avoir un nouveau nouvelles envies de
décentralisation c'est donc en ce qui me
concerne moi mais je fais confiance aux
aux rapporteurs pour peut-être compléter
votre question mais je voudrais
simplement vous dire nous partîmes 20
avec la ministre nous pourrions aller à
et pourquoi pas approcher les 50 c'est
l'objectif de l'examen que nous avons
président des faits c'est très gentil de
la parole mais je vais pas rajouté grand
chose à tout ce que vous avez dit de les
deux rapporteurs de la commission des
lois où ce qu'a dit le président du
sénat peut être une seule observation
qui est celle sur laquelle ce texte
d'importance pour le sénat maison des
collectivités territoriales est d'abord
on a d'abord la volonté d'un texte
pragmatique
l'idée on l'a compris c'est pas la
révolution institutionnelle ce texte
d'abord on n'en veut pas mais c'est en
revanche la volonté absolue d'être au
service des élus et des territoires et
de donner aux acteurs des territoires
tous les outils simples d' usage
efficace pour les populations car
allongé une fois de plus il est là nous
sommes au service des populations et
c'est pour elle qu'il faut que les
maires les pattes des conseillers
départementaux ou régionaux aient la
capacité de pouvoir agir le plus
librement possible avec la plus grande
efficacité possible si ça je crois le
fil rouge reste que l'état ne doit pas
disparaître
on a bien compris que la proposition
numéro 6 en tout cas le point numéro 6
qui a été évoqué c'est bien celui sur
lequel l'état doit continuer sa présence
alors évidemment l'actualité fait que
l'on parle des préfets et de genres
éventuelle disparition
moi j'ai un souvenir qui n'est pas si
lointain que ça à la crise de 2008 crise
financière si l'on n'est pas ce que le
président de la république de l'époque a
mis en place le plan de relance et je
repense en particulier notre le ministre
monsieur devedjian un instant où je vous
parle qui était le ministre en charge
j'ai été à la demande du président du
sénat parlementaire en mission auprès de
monsieur de vie dure je peux vous dire
qu'à partir du moment où les
instructions politiques étaient claires
précises déterminer les services de
l'état se sont mobilisés de façon
remarquable et ont été d'une efficacité
remarquable
la question c'est pas la remise en cause
des services de l'état la question c'est
la capacité de les coordonnées de les
piloter de leur donner les lignes et les
caps pour qu'ils avancent
y a rien de pire que une absence de
consigne qui fait que finalement tout le
monde se cherche
lorsque il ya un moment difficile c'est
comme ça qu'il faut fonctionner il faut
tenir le cap
voilà sa violence que je voulais dire à
ce stade merci juste oui juste rajouté
par cette question les ailes et à mon
avis essentiel et j'évoquais tout à
l'heure dans propos la constance du
sénat mais je crois que les faits sont
têtus
et vous verrez dans ce texte qu'on
retrouvera des positions du sénat issu
de la loi notre des points sur lesquels
nous avions à l'époque alertés et que
nous retrouverons comme je le disais sur
sur ce texte cadets et qui à mon avis
trouveront un écho peut-être un peu plus
favorable de la part du gouvernement
d'ailleurs le président vient de le dire
mais on voit bien et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui s'est passé sur engagement et
proximité engagement et proximité c'est
quand même l'émanation d'une immense
partie des travaux du sénat sur les
conditions d'exercice des élus locaux
sur la concertation que nous avions
menée à l'époque sur le problème de
sécurité qui nous avaient amenés à des
échanges avec notamment au ministère de
la justice sur la question de l'exercice
des compétences au sein du bloc communal
autant de sujets qui provenaient des
travaux du sénat donc je dirais tout
simplement qu'il n'ya pas lieu avoir une
attitude frondeuse
dès lors que finalement le texte va où
ira dans le sens qui est le sens
souhaité par par le sénat qui lui même
reprend je dire à son compte via les
consultations que nous venons d'évoquer
la parole des élus des associations
d'élus donc l'émanation des aspirations
d'aidé et des élus locaux et ça je pense
que c'est important parce que dès lors
on ne peut être que sur une position
pragmatique par contre et je mens
arrêterait là mais il est nécessaire
aussi que parce que nous basons sur ces
concertations et ces consultations le
gouvernement puisse être en capacité
d'entendre le besoin de mesures
complémentaires qui ne se retrouverait
pas dans dans ce texte et je pense qu'il
y à quelques sujets on a évoqué la
question des ressources des des
collectivités la question des ressources
par aux transferts de compétences je
pense qu'il y a des manques sur ce sujet
nous l'avions déjà soulevée lors
d'engagements et proximité il y à
d'autres sujets qui ne se retrouvent pas
dans ce texte et que nous essaierons
tant que faire se peut
de venir compléter comme nous l'avons
fait sur sur le texte engagement
proximité un mot monsieur roger je pense
que je vous remercie parce que vous avez
parfaitement répondu à ma question
parfait alors je me proposais n'ont pas
de surenchérir mais de donner en écho le
ressenti eux que j'aime et que nous
partagions tous
je pense que la situation de notre pays
est si grave que la posture ne
conviendrait pas et que je crois que sur
tous ces textes comme sur d'autres le
sénat a montré qu'avant tout il
s'agissait comme l'a dit le président
buffet n'ont pas de différenciation de
déconcentration ce qui ne sont jamais
que des outils mais c'est l'obligation
de résultats que nous avons pour nos
populations jusqu'au dernier kilomètre
car nous avons une vraie crise de
confiance dans ce pays et qu'il est
exigeant pour nous de devoir travailler
tous ensemble et moi je salue aussi la
ténacité de la ministre qui a sorti un
fils un peu ténu mais elle sait qu'elle
peut faire confiance au sénat pour
l'enrichir et vraiment faire de ce film
aurait pelote de laine et que les élus
locaux ne sont pas dans le caprice ou la
négation de 2,2 les tailles de l'unité
de la république ils sont juste dans
l'exigence d'efficacité et de résultats
et le sénat saura être exigeant mais
mais mais constructive on l'a vu
d'engagements et proximité mais mathieu
darnaud l'a dit comme nous avons à
plusieurs reprises dit des choses
suggéré est exigée ça n'est pas juste
par obstruction ou par obsession c'est
parce que nous sommes convaincus au
travers de ce que nous voyons avec notre
expérience d'élu d'élu local et de ce
que nous disent les élus qu'il ya des
choses qui doivent bouger dans
engagement et proximité nous avons été
entendus engagement et proximité c'est
quoi c'est le résultat de l'évaluation
des lois territoriales que le sénat a
fait et le goût
armement a su nous entendent donc soyons
confiants en tout cas nous nous sommes
constructifs
alors je crois que j'ai retrouvé
monsieur césar arman il y à arnaud
paillardes l'aef est aussi nous avons
deux questions écrites
monsieur armand alors monsieur paillard
voilà voilà monsieur armand pardon bon
mais alors bon écoutez monsieur armand
ou vous voit vous garde alors je vous en
prie je vous en prie alors on n'a pas de
sens par contre voilà voilà que je me
sens prêt et très bien allez-y
merci madame la présidente messieurs les
sénateurs
qu'est-ce que vous aurez un exemple de a
donné dans chacun des des eaux pour vos
attentes
une attente à transmettre blanche un dd
de ce projet de loi
je vous remercie merci monsieur alors
avec monsieur arnaud payao peut prendre
votre question ce qui va laisser le
temps de répondre au questionnaire que
je me donnais monsieur armand oui
bonjour vous demanderez oui et non pas
fière de l'aef vous aviez lancé une
consultation auprès de 3300 élu je
voulais vous demander si vous avez pu
identifier des remontées de la part des
élus urbains parce que le projet loi
parle de de pas mal de passes
d'urbanistes notamment de grandes
opérations de balises et d'obtention de
revitalisation des territoires jeu sera
signaux sur votre panel d'élus vous avez
pu identifier des remontées propre
vraiment sur des questions d'urbanisme
de la part des élus notamment un ratio
je vais peut-être proposer de répondre à
la deuxième question sur la
préoccupation des urba en matière
d'urbanisme
mathieu darnaud l'un peut expliquer il y
a des interrogations assez fortes qui
ont fait l'objet d'une enquête d'une
consultation spécifique
par la commission des affaires
économiques en la personne de dominique
estrosi sassone et valérie l'état parce
que les opérations d'urbanisme sont un
véritable enjeu et mathieu darnaud il a
dit aujourd'hui on a pensé régler la
question du logement et de
l'accessibilité au logement pour tous
par une obligation de construction de
logements sociaux dans les communes les
plus grandes
or on voit que le fait de taxer les
communes qui ne répondent pas à ces
objectifs ne suffit pas à produire du
logement parce qu'il ya parfois une
impossibilité à faire parce que je sois
ya peu de terrains disponibles au
foncier est très très cher donc il va y
avoir un rapport qui va sortir très
prochainement sur cette question de
l'urbanisme dans les métropoles
notamment et d'autres pas il y aussi une
mission en cours au sein de la
délégation aux collectivités sur les
métropoles et nous avons plusieurs
questions notamment sur la
différenciation ou les élus des
métropoles disent que le transfert
obligatoire de compétences et de la
totalité des compétences contre vient
parfois l'efficacité de l'action
publique et je donnerai un exemple qui
est devenu célèbre au sénat et qui sera
une première réponse à votre collègue si
celui de la voirie dans les métropoles
toute la voirie a été transféré au
métropole
or nous voyons qu'il convient de
distinguer les axes structurants de
voirie sur lesquelles passent les le
transport que ce soit à métro un tram ou
des bus et la petite rue de la 47e
commune qui tue n'ont eu en impasse dans
un lotissement où là la question de la
voirie une question dit nids-de-poule
c'est à dire cette chaussée qui se
creuse sur laquelle il faut intervenir
rapidement et que sans aucun doute que
la métropole très centralisé très
organisée n'est pas l'outil le plus
agile
pour régler le fameux nid poule
metropolit a donc on est toujours dans
cette question de subsidiarité de
proximité mathieu tu as sûrement eu
pléthore d'exemples pour répondre à la
question sur un exemple pour chaque d
sinon je vais m'astreindre de façon plus
synthétique a essayé de répondre sur le
1er déc et la décentralisation qui est
quand même
l'ouvragé principal ce qu'on souhaite
c'est vraiment traiter la question de la
décentralisation
sur l'ensemble du champ parce qu'il
serait faux de penser que la
décentralisation c'est simplement de
paris vers la province
aujourd'hui je le dis parce que l'une
des principales critiques que nous avons
a objecté par rapport notamment la
fusion des régions
c'est con à recentraliser à l'échelle
des régions mais on l'a fait aussi à
l'échelle des grandes intercommunalités
dit xxl et nous de façon très claire on
souhaite vraiment redonné la souplesse
nécessaire pour que au sein d'une région
une région puissent s'entendre avec la
liberté conventionnelle avec un
département pour cogérer
une compétence dès lors qu'il y aurait
une spécificité territoriale je pense
notamment aux problèmes de mobilité dans
les départements à certains problèmes
économiques dans d'autres départements
et donc pouvoir qu agir entre guillemets
entre les deux niveaux de collectivités
idem et nous remettrons un peu le
couvert parce que pour aller de 30 à 50
monsieur le président il ya 20 sujets
qui restent en suspens et parmi ces
sujets nous on est assez têtu sur la
question du bloc communal parce qu'on
n'a toujours pas trouvé la juste réponse
à ceux des élus et notamment des maires
notamment sur les territoires ruraux qui
considère qu'on a fait des
intercommunalités parfois trop grande et
qu'on devrait pouvoir aujourd'hui
repenser la ventilation de certaines
compétences sans forcément enfermer des
compétences dans des blocs ou dans des
grands pans où on aurait un nombre de
compétences obligatoires ça là aussi
nous nous y reviendrons donc on va
lutter contre toutes les formes
finalement de de centralisme qui
contreviennent j'allais dire aux maîtres
mots qui est celui de proximité qui est
aussi important dans la bouche des élus
locaux que dans la bouche de nos
concitoyens sur la différenciation et je
n'oublie pas parce qu'il ya aussi un
volet qu'on n'a pas évoqué les
territoires ultramarins la
différenciation vous le savez les
territoires ultramarins ont été un peu
pionnier en la matière notamment sur le
texte égalité réelle
outre mer que j'avais eu la chance de le
rapporter il y a maintenant plusieurs
années et je crois qu'on doit aussi
s'inspirer de ça c'est à dire qu'on est
dans un cadre on est dans une république
une et indivisible et ça on tient à le
rappeler ici au sénat parce qu'il ne
s'agirait pas de faire de la
différenciation un outil pour finalement
abîmés ou venir contrarier les grands
principes républicains et la
construction et l'architecturé de nos
institutions et notamment de nos
collectivités territoriales en revanche
on s'autorise à penser qu'il y a des
fois des ajustements notamment dans la
façon d'appréhender ça a été fait par
exemple sur la collectivité européenne
d'alsace mais il faut encore une fois
raison garder et faire en sorte que tout
ça puisse se concilier avec l'existence
notamment
des régions donc différenciation c'est
permettre vraiment de pouvoir aussi via
l'expérimentation laisser un département
qui le souhaiteraient une compétence
parce qu'ils seraient en proximité ou le
mieux à même de l'exercer comme ça a été
le cas notamment sur les collectivités
ultramarines sans que bien sûr ça
contreviennent à l'esprit de la loi et à
la loi en règle générale et puis des
complexification de vous à moi c'est
peut-être le plus le sujet le plus
difficile
on s'y attaquer au travers des moules
des multiples travaux de la délégation
aux collectivités en essayant de vouloir
briser et faire diminuer le stock de
normes ça on y est parvenu par contre il
ya une maladie qui est chronique c'est
le flux de normes c'est à dire qu'on en
pont et là il ya quelque chose de très
important sur lequel il faut qu'on soit
en capacité d'agir et c'est pour ça que
nous aurons des propositions vis-à-vis
du renforcement de la place et du rôle
du conseil national d'évaluation des
normes parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
instances dans lesquelles les élus
locaux sièges parce que c'est eux et eux
seuls qui sont à même de nous dire ce
qui peut paraître excessif totalement
incompatible avec la réalité
territoriale et les moyens des
collectivités
j'ai oublié le des déconcentrations vous
me le pardonnerai je vais y venir tout
de suite parce que pour nous c'est
peut-être un des écueils de ce texte
c'est quand on parle de déconcentration
on est essentiellement sur le champ
réglementaire et donc la marge qui est
laissée au champ législatif est
relativement faible mais nous avons déjà
commencé à évoquer le sujet avec la
ministre de montchanin pour nous c'est
très clair la déconcentration celle
inverse de ce par quoi nous avons
attaqué cette conférence de presse et
surtout pas s'attaquer à l'état
territorial et aux couples préfet
sous-préfet qui a cette agilité
nécessaire qui peut permettre de gérer
des situations compliquées dans des
territoires et qui doivent être
renforcés conforté par ce texte
avec finalement la deuxième jambe qui
est celle des collectivités donc voilà
un peu l'esprit qui sera le nôtre
déconcentration pour nous ça permettra
aussi de mettre plus d'ingénierie dans
les territoires il ya des sujets sur le
sur le serema pour permettre d'avoir de
l'ingénierie notamment dans les
territoires ruraux
travailler avec l'agencé nationale de
cohésion des territoires
tous ces outils qui ne doivent pas
finalement être laissé de côté mais être
au centre du jeu pour permettre
justement aux élus locaux de trouver
l'ingénierie et de faire naître des
projets sur leur territoire merci
beaucoup alors il y à deux questions
écrites une première de marguerittes ont
revu comtec qui porte sur le chapitre du
transport nous demandant quelle est la
position du sénat et des élus locaux sur
les transferts de route à titre
expérimental aux régions ceci s'inscrit
dans la conception que nous avons de la
loi qui doit permettre et non pas
imposer c'est à dire nous nous
souhaitons que la loi elle ouvre ce que
j'appelle le champ des possibles pour
fabriquer des solutions si une région
veut par exemple avoir des lignes
ferroviaires secondaires dès lors que l
contractualiser avec l'état sur un
transfert de compétences qui soit
acceptable
y compris financièrement nous nous
souhaitons que cela soit possible et que
ce ne soit pas une décentralisation
verticale c'est à dire que l'état ne
disent pas ce jeune homme
l'ensemble des routes nationales aux
régions non nous nous sommes pour une
décentralisation plus tôt bottom up
c'est elle la région qui a besoin parce
qu'elle sera efficace elle le fera bien
si elle demande elle pourra elle pourra
le faire donc c'est bien cette idée
d'une loi qui va permettre et qui a la
main des élus locaux pour pouvoir
construire les solutions qui seront
adaptés dans le cantal et la bretagne ne
prendra pas les mêmes et encore moins de
l'outre-mer une question un peu général
que je reprendrai tout à l'heure en
matière de conclusion parce que monsieur
gritton vous vous vous nous dites que vu
les manques que nous avons souligné le
sénat va-t-il essayer de réécrire
intégralement le texte donc je
regarderai ça pour le mot de la fin est
une question monsieur labeur de rcr sur
les préfets monsieur président du sénat
beaucoup insisté sur l'importance du
coup
le maire préfète qui a été révélé aux
yeux de tous y compris ceux qui n'est
pas de culture de l'action publique qui
a été révélé comme le seul levier de
l'efficacité pendant la crise sanitaire
c'est bien la compétence du couple état
collectivité vous dites que la
suppression du corps préfectoral est de
nature à vous inquiéter
je me dirais autrement puisque le la
consultation que l'on vient de présenter
montre l'exigence des élus du besoin
d'un état qui soit un état facilitateur
et autant les élus des grandes villes ou
des grandes métropoles ont un contact
assez naturelle avec le préfet autant
nous savons que notamment dans les
territoires ruraux
le sous-préfet et celui qui démêle c'est
le guichet unique pour un maire qui
vient porter une question un problème
qui doit trouver une solution et le sous
préfet va activer l'ensemble des arcanes
des services de l'état et des agences
pour construire la solution avec les
élus touché au corps préfectoral s'est
vraiment touché à l'efficacité de
l'action publique puisque amer est
l'incarnation de la république sur le
terrain mais il doit pouvoir travailler
avec l'incarnation de l'état qui va
garantir l'harmonie des décisions et
cette fabrique d'une solution alors
naturellement je crois que là on a des
points de vue qui sont sans doute un peu
qu'ils sont sans doute un peu différent
et sur lesquels il conviendra de revenir
donc le monsieur grippe ton peut-être
pour le mot de la fin vous demandez donc
s'il sénat va essayer de réécrire
intégralement le texte il ya deux façons
de faire les choses sur le gouvernement
écrit sa copie lé sénat écrit une copie
et puis nous nous regardent en chiens de
faïence chacun étant content de ce qu'il
a fait mais on n'a pas atteint
l'objectif
ce que je rappelle que l'objectif c'est
d'être utile au pays
utile aux habitants est donnée aux élus
locaux les moyens d'assumer les
compétences qui sont les leurs donc le
sénat n'arrive pas masquer si je puis
dire puisque depuis on va dire l'an
dernier depuis le mois de juillet
dernier le sénat en la personne de son
président a présenté les 50 propositions
qui lui semblait être pertinente pour
faire avancer le pays
nous sortons aussi d'un texte engagement
et proximité qui a repris l'évaluation
faite par le sénat de la loi note et
dans la loi engagement et proximité nous
avons déjà exprimé au ministre le soin
et la nécessité d'aller un pont plus
loin donc je crois que la mini je salue
aussi encore une fois sa ténacité pour
sortir un fils elle lui tend une main en
quelques ça nous nous lui tendons les
bras dès lors que effectivement elle va
s'efforcer d'aller au delà de cases ou
de vin et qu'encore une fois nous ne
serons pas contre le gouvernement nous
ne serons pas contre ces propositions
mais je crois que le gouvernement ne
peut qu entendre les propositions que
nous faisons parce que c'est celle qui
s'est aussi exprimée par les élus locaux
et ici nous n'avons qu'une seule volonté
c'est de pouvoir construire être utile
et faire que ce pays puisse sortir des
deux crises des gilets jaunes et décrit
ce n'était en ayant tiré des leçons pour
que si j'ose dire on ne connaisse plus
jamais ça et quand je dis plus jamais ça
c'est les défaillances que nous avons
connu les retards parce que nous
n'étions pas dans cette harmonie et
cette complicité positive d'un couple
qui est celui de l'état et des
collectivités
alors ya laurent thévenot à laurent
thevenon qui a une dernière question
monsieur thévenaz les échos vous voulez
savoir sur le plan financier
quelle était votre principale attente
puisque en étable le texte d'abord
passer cette question là alors il est
vrai que le texte n'apporte pas de
réponse je rappelle que le sénat a fait
deux propositions extrêmement précises
c'est la juste compensation de transfert
de compétences et surtout un poids
extrêmement fort qui est celui de la
révision du coût des compétences
transférées puisque on l'a vu sur par
exemple le rsa quand le gouvernement
transfère au département la gestion du
rsa
ce n'est pas le département qui
configure le champ du rsa et son
évolution c'est l'état où la loi qui
viennent imposer de nouvelles
obligations aux départements et que dès
lors qu'il ya de nouvelles obligations
fixées par l'état ou par la loi à une
collectivité
ces nouvelles obligations dès lors
qu'elles ont un coût financier et en
général c'est toujours le cas doivent
être compensés à celui à qui on a
délégué la compétence
mathieu je sens que tu es très inspiré
par cette question justin un mot de
complément puisque nous avons voté là
aussi un et choses sont très claires il
y a de cela maintenant six mois ici même
au sénat une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle puisque vous savez que
nous sommes très attachés à ce principe
qui décident paix et les deux
dispositions que vient de d'évoquer
françoise gatel qui ont été aussi voter
dans ce dans ce même texte ont pour seul
but de garantir aux présidents des
exécutifs des départements des régions
et de l'ensemble des collectivités qui
se verrait transférer des compétences
l'assurance qu'ils auront bien la
ressource qui va avec parce
qu'aujourd'hui et encore une fois on l'a
dit en introduction
c'est là où le bât peut blesser
et nous au sénat nous considérons que si
on veut accompagner ces mouvements de
déconcentration ces mouvement de
décentralisation et faire en même temps
de la différenciation il est absolument
nécessaire à un moment donné de parler
de la question des ressources parce que
sinon les collectivités dont beaucoup
sont à loos disons les choses très
clairement n'auront pas les capacités
d'assumer ces transferts de compétences
ça c'est essentiel
et j'ajouterais même que nous
réfléchissons depuis longtemps président
paraît de la conférence nationale des
territoires nous posons comme un besoin
impérieux de revoir la question des
péréquations si on veut que dans ce pays
les collectivités puissent vivre
durablement que les métropoles
cohabitant intelligemment avec les
territoires plus ruraux il faut penser
la question de la péréquation
sans quoi on va creuser un fossé qui
d'antan sera mortifère merci merci merci
à tous de votre présence de votre
attention de votre intérêt de voûte du
sivu attentive que nous vous ne
manquerez pas de faire un aux travaux vu
l'intérêt que ces singes elle alors le
président me charge de rappeler à juste
titre que les travaux du sénat
commenceront le 5 juillet en hémicycle
merci à tous
[Musique]